hello everyone and welcome back to some
rapid daily action where I will play a
rapid game and try to explain my thought
process to the best of my abilities uh
and uh we are of course after that
preparing for the Magnus versus Wesley
so finals uh of the champion Chester
finals so our opponent for today is
fifo uh yeah it seems that I already
have a victory against him uh but I
don't think he was in Rapid time format
uh I will check what what was this uh
thing that we played Okay so he goes for
E6 and D5 uh what kind of a fringe
defense will it be uh we'll see okay so
Knight to C3 we're just fighting for D4
square and it's the uh Vin variation I
believe and we're going to advance our
Pawn to E5 and he goes for C5 and it's a
pretty standard setup uh I already feel
that I'm at a disadvantage uh since I'm
not really well versed in this line uh I
know some ideas like you could play
something like A4 you could go for Queen
to G4 Queen to G4 I think is the most
the interesting way to play and also
the and also the main idea uh but yeah
let's
uh so uh captures and captures is
possible I know that for a fact but I
don't know how to play
that so might not be a terrible idea to
let our opponent show us why why you
should and shouldn't play it all right
we're going to play captur Capt is going
to capture here put pressure on this
Pawn and uh also put pressure on the E5
pawn and now we have to figure out a
move what's uh what's a move
here like certainly certainly not Bishop
to
D2 because then if he captures what then
then I play Bishop to F4 is such a thing
even
possible um yeah Knight to F3 okay we
defend this but then we give up the C3
Pawn I like this perfectly fine like
maybe even Bishop to B5 check but then I
really weakened the G2 Pawn so I don't
think that's the way to do
it yeah let's go like this let's go like
this but then he can capture
here yeah okay let's do it let's see
what's the
idea let's see what the idea is yeah and
you see how I already I'm already down
two minutes but not knowing my
openings so uh yeah we'll definitely
check out this one after the game how to
play it and now I might even give up D5
Pawn maybe with Bishop to E3 but uh yeah
know let's just see let's just see how
how you play
this how do you play it okay so he goes
after the pawn we're just going to
defend the
pawn
huh
yeah and he will Castle Queen side which
okay I mean it's definitely playable
we're going to put our Bishop on D3 just
uh because he might go Knight to F5 at
some point and we want to be ready with
the
captures yeah and if he castles Queen
side I'm going to Castle King set and
put my Bishop on G3 sort of to help me
guard uh along the G file and I don't
know it's not much like it's equal
material and he will have pressure on
the king side I will have pressure on
the queen
side can we just Castle here and uh say
it's perfectly
fine yeah I'm sure we
can and if he goes for Knight G6 or
something I take yeah I just capture
where wherever the Knight goes uh the
Knight really should go somewhere like
F5 or here uh and he should also look
looking uh look into doubling up here uh
maybe even Rook h8 Queen G7 Rook G8
Queen
F6 and then
something yeah my queen uh no he goes
for F5 yeah he really wants
the oh since my Bishop is sort of
hanging here but uh yeah okay captures
alasan he captures the bishop
here I capture the Knight he captures
the Knight here threatens Checkmate but
then I captured The Rook what am I
missing uh what am I missing I'm pretty
sure I'm missing
something like captures captures he
gives up the Knight but then doesn't
capture KN he maybe recap nah okay show
me show me okay so he goes for that we
capture
here and then Rook h8 is that the
idea but then he no longer has the
threat
uh yeah very interesting stuff very
interesting stuff here
huh
yeah captur might not even be possible
but what what what is there if not
captures Queen
H4 and doesn't look like uh doesn't look
like a great move and if I if I don't
capture back I'm just down a piece so I
have to capture whatever no he's just
going to capture back
yeah now he's threatening Queen captures
Knight
H pretty sure he could have played this
better yeah capture here he captures the
Knight threatens
mate uh but we just play
G3 and he opens up the
diagonal so go for Bishop
here
ah yeah very
interesting most interesting
yes
but I don't think it's uh I don't think
it's that
powerful
okay oh that's the
stuff that's the stuff
nice yeah he takes it with check
wow yeah very nice
just very nice indeed yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah no way to block
okay yeah missed the move order there a
little bit all right so I definitely
have to have to improve on the VIN
variation uh but yeah I I I wanted to
take everything and see what happens and
he showed me what happens so good game
Mr fifo uh yeah E5 C5 okay I know this
is perfectly fine and here Queen G4 sort
of the main line uh I did go for
captures and I captured yeah it says
it's perfectly fine he played C captures
on D4 and
now yeah sort of just uh just Knight
E2 yeah that seems to be the way to play
it yeah yeah you should know stuff like
that and then after C but what if Queen
captures on E5 yeah that doesn't matter
just he captures on e4 so he's going to
capture here and uh I defend with F4
yeah that's the way to do it not the way
I did it I went Bishop to D2 he went to
for this and Bishop to F4 but yeah this
is still z00 territory I played Knight
to F3 he played this I played this he
castled I went for castles yeah okay
Bishop to G3 first sort of maybe an
improvement and uh here I thought that
he he he's the one that missed the idea
but it was actually me who missed the
idea yeah I should just continue with
the Rook eight to
B1 and
uh not worry about my queen being
trapped is the that correct like what
this just Queen F7 and if he goes this I
go Queen G7 oh so okay then Queen here
yeah we can either get some sort of a
repetition
here yeah okay so yeah probably some
sort of a repetition here if I uh just
go Rook B1 but captures yeah immediately
Queen captures on F4 I captured he
captured on G2 no yeah Rook Rook G2
funny how we both missed this for the
first time but then he founded the
second time yeah yeah now it's made in
seven yeah here obviously you can still
hold maybe a little bit with Knight E5
but yeah Rook h8 I have to play G3 and
it's a uh it's a much better end game
for him yeah Miss Miss missed a brutal
tactic there yeah but just captures
captures Rook G2 King here and now it's
a a fine fine uh ending sequence uh but
yeah uh for those of you who enjoy
playing against the French
a little thing to learn about the wi
variation uh make sure once you once you
take all the pawns make sure to go
Knight E2 yeah and you do that and
you'll be completely fine and I'll make
sure to remember it for for the next
time I go into it but uh you know uh if
anything we have learned a lot from this
game uh so yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and also uh improving your
vast knowledge with some daily rapid
action uh see you
soon